[MUSIC PLAYING]
CECILE LEROUX: So when it
comes to some of the challenges
in rolling out and actually
embracing a new approach
that really stresses how people
can bring their authentic self
to work, and it
required us to change,
for example, our approach
to talent acquisition
or recruiting, as one example--
it's not OK to have limited
interview pools, for example.
We had to make sure
that we demanded more.
So often-- and I'm sure
anyone who's hearing this,
it's like, oh, well,
we couldn't find enough
of x, y, or z candidates.
Well, then you've
got to look harder.
And so that means
taking a second look
at where and how we actually
approach and describe
our organization.
So this emphasis
has to be authentic.
It has to be true.
And so when we put together
interview teams, when
we think about
development programs,
sponsorship programs--
it's not just mentorship,
but sponsorship programs--
we're always thinking about
and we're always
including what will this
mean to diverse candidates?
What outcomes will
they want to have?
How do we understand
cultural differences
and actually embrace those
as part of what we do?
And that's how you make
it part of your DNA.
So there were challenges
in overcoming.
You can't just go to
the usual suspects.
You've got to look differently.
You've got to think differently.
We've seen a two-fold increase
in different categories.
In some of our
regions, for example,
we've actually
doubled the number
of women in technology, which
is a great result that we're
really excited about.
We look to other
organizations that we can also
model and learn from.
And so I do want to thank
Google for recognizing us,
not only for our
diversity, equity,
and our belonging efforts, but
also for our new technology
approach, Life-Work
Technology, that
has allowed us to not just
collaborate but really advance
UKG and take a different
approach, not just to how
we support our customers,
but also how we work
and how we come and present
ourselves in the marketplace.
So it's a huge honor
for us, but one
that we are excited to
earn again and continue
to advance our relationship and
our partnership with Google.
So thank you so much,
Google, for these awards.
[MUSIC PLAYING]